hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in Section 2 of his inquiry concerning
human understanding David Hume is going
to elaborate a distinction for us that
is absolutely central to his philosophy
and he's using terms that we have come
to be very familiar with perhaps a
little bit too familiar because we we
use them in a very broad sense and Hume
once to distinguish them from each other
so these are technical terms in human
philosophy
they're both signifying different ways
that the human mind perceives things
including things that it may make itself
for its own States and he calls these on
the one hand impressions on the other
hand ideas or thoughts of the human mind
and we have to be very very careful
because we often talk in terms of having
an idea of something in ways that is a
little bit different than what what Hume
would say and we also talked about
having impressions in a way that would
correspond to what he here is calling
ideas or thoughts for example when we
meet somebody and some
what was your first impression of them
and we have to think about it and we say
well I suppose that they are a little
bit full of themself or they are a very
nice person or they could have dressed
themselves a bit better or I in a hard
time following what they are saying
we're relying on our memory and strictly
speaking what we're actually providing
the other person is not actually our
impressions we're providing them with
something different which is our ideas
which we're putting into words so what
is the distinction here Hume begins Hume
is a very good composer or writer he
begins with a nice contrast here he says
everyone will readily allow there's a
considerable difference between the
perceptions of the mind when a person
feels the pain of excessive heat of the
pleasure of moderate warmth and when he
afterwards recalls it to his memory this
sensation or anticipates it by his
imagination these faculties may mimic or
copy the perceptions of the senses but
they can never entirely reach the force
and vivacity of the original sentiment
and he goes on a little bit more saying
that the utmost we say even when they
operate with greatest vigor say of what
imagination and memory is that they
represent their object in so lively a
manner that we could keyword almost say
that we feel or see it but they don't
actually arrive at that level of
velocity the term that he's using
liveliness right so impressions are
things which we actually experience they
are what what is coming in from the
outside to the mind or perhaps it could
also be impressions from what it is that
we're experiencing internally so things
that we sense through the intermediaries
of the five senses or however many we
have and then things that we feel and
what are the things that we feel the
passions Hume says willing or volition
he's
to talk about that is something that we
actually have an impression not just an
idea of and desire and aversion so the
effective and the sensible or sense
sensuous we could say right that is what
we have impressions of and then ideas
are actually copies he says or
representations of those things and he
says that we can recall them to memory
if you think about all the many things
that you can remember remember you know
what I was saying just a few minutes ago
right you were there and you were
hearing that at that time now of course
you could back up the the soundtrack and
hear it again in which case you can you
can awaken it right but you you can
recall it to memory as well and it may
not be as as strong or you can imagine
it the imagination is this very
interesting productive capacity that we
have as human beings but there's a
fundamental difference between them
what's the difference for hume the
difference resides primarily in what we
could call the strength of the
perception how it impresses itself upon
us uses words like forcible lively
strong for the things that are
impression so you know when we're
actually seeing something in front of us
happening or you know you could say I
suppose when we're experiencing it
through media I mean this is very
interesting to think about in the world
that we live in where much of what it is
that we see here even sometimes smell is
something that's being reproduced right
we watch something we listen to music
which obviously we can't have a band
there the entire time to do that we
smells are a little bit different in
that we have to have some actual thing
that we're smelling that we're taking in
through our nose although you could have
fake smells of things as well right but
those are strong we're experiencing
those
at the time then the ideas or thoughts
are less forcible or lively he also
talks about them as being weak being
faint in other places he's going to talk
about them as being abstract when we are
considering thoughts particularly those
to which we have as human says United a
term and we assume that there's some
sort of impression corresponding to it
right so we have this this distinction
here what we actually experience at
first is quite strong and then the the
material that we have is is weaker so so
far so good I don't think that too many
people would find this difficult or
challenging to accept another key issue
with this is that impressions are not
things that we necessarily choose to
have I mean we can say we put ourselves
into situations where we experience them
so for example when I go to have my meal
later on I'm taking the the fork and
putting food into my mouth and then I'm
having a you know a taste and odor
sensation also tactile sensations a lot
of taste is actually mouthfeel alright
so you can say that that's that's up to
me in a certain respect but I don't
actually choose to have this interaction
between my my Oregon of tastes the
tongue whatever else is going on as well
and the food it impresses itself upon me
and there's all sorts of things that we
taste or smell or hear or see or feel
that we we don't really want to feel we
we would rather have some control over
it and not feel those things so that's a
good example of things that impinge upon
us are imposed upon us with ideas they
can be composed by us they are to a
certain respect volitional Hume goes on
and says nothing at first view may seem
more unbounded than the thought of man
she not only escapes all human power and
authority but has not even restrained
within the limits of nature and reality
to form monsters and join incongruous
shapes and appearances
costs the imagination no more trouble
than to conceive the most natural and
familiar objects and he says we have
this we seem to possess this unbounded
Liberty but actually it's really
confined within very narrow limits all
that this creative power of the mind the
imagination amounts to no more than the
Faculty of compounding transposing
augmenting or diminishing the materials
afforded to us by the senses and
experience and he gives you some
examples here golden mountain right
have you any of you ever seen a golden
mountain in real life a mountain really
made of gold no but can you imagine that
easily just imagine a mountain now make
it made of gold right or a little bit
more difficult a virtuous horse we take
the figure and shape of horse and then
from our own feeling we conceive virtue
and he says in all these cases all the
materials of thinking are derived from
our outward or inward sentiment the
mixture and composition of these alone
belongs to the mind and will or to
express myself in philosophical language
all our ideas or more feeble perceptions
are copies of our impressions or more
lively ones not necessarily copies in a
exact sense but but copies of what we
take in through the senses or through
our sentiments and passions that
furnishes the raw material which then
the mind can work upon if we consider
some examples I think this drives Humes
point home quite well so we began with
talking about a feeling of heat and he
actually distinguished two things a very
hot thing and a pleasant warmth right
when you're experiencing these that is
quite different than merely having an
idea remembering or imagining or
thinking about the sensation of heat
imagine right now that you are coming in
from a cold day you've just done some
chores outside maybe
chopping wood or you know cleaning up
the yard and you're you're shivering a
little bit and you go in and you sit in
front of the nice warm fire let's even
make it more sensuous not only there's a
sensation of warmth there's also the
smell of the wood smoke and the cheery
you know glow of the the flame and that
they you know the embers and all of that
sort of stuff you're picturing it right
it's not the same thing as actually
being there though and having those
sensations as a matter of fact we'll
talk about more examples in a moment
Hume says that people who do experience
ideas of the mind as if they were
impressions are disordered they're a
month he says unless the mind be
disordered by disease or madness these
ideas can never arise at such a pitch of
the vasa tea as to render these
perceptions altogether indistinguishable
he says all the colors of poetry can
never paint natural objects in such a
manner as to make the description be
taken for a real landscape the most
lively thought is still inferior to the
dullest sensation and we might say in
our own case well wait a second what
about movies or virtual reality people
get sucked into that Hume would say well
they're responding to it as if they're
responding to the impressions that
they're getting they're not really just
working with ideas if they're working
with ideas and they think that they're
as strong as impressions then they have
some problem another great example that
Hume brings up that I think shows us a
different modality a fit of anger I'm
sure that all of you know what it's like
to lose your temper and to be angry what
the sensation of that is like or rather
the perception if we want to be a little
bit more clear because it's not felt
through the senses as such but rather a
passion that we experience it's not the
same thing as remembering what it's like
to be angry unless we make ourselves
angry again in which case we're having
the impression again right you think
about sob and the
he did to me and now you get yourself
angry now you're actually having the
impression but if you only think about
in terms of the idea it's not as strong
it's not as distinct it's not as lively
he gives another example the relish of
wine and says that this is unknown to
people living in other places right it
gives a laplander you know somebody
who's living in in finland quite high up
presumably there's not wine readily
available there although nowadays of
course it is would not have the
impression of that and therefore could
not actually form the idea of it
he has another great example as well he
says that a selfish heart cannot easily
conceive the heights of friendship and
generosity right somebody who doesn't
actually know what it feels like to be
friendly and to be generous is not going
to be able to form a very good that is
faithful idea of it as a matter of fact
they may not be able to form any idea of
it according to Hugh may have the word
but the word doesn't actually correspond
to an idea in their mind just to kind of
jumble of stuff that they may mistake
for it so those are good examples I
think for driving home what this
distinction between impressions and
ideas of the mind are remember they're
all perceptions they're all ways in
which were grasping a reality either
external to or internal to ourselves but
they differ from each other in these
several ways of where they come from how
lively or strong they are whether we
have any degree of you know volition
when it comes to them and a relationship
of being copies or representations of
the ideas or copies or representations
of the impressions which we could also
you know we can compound them to form
new ideas but they're always going to be
drawn from the
material of impressions according to
Hugh
you